new york berlin london und anderen
metropolen allesamt bedeckt von einer
achtung drei kilometer dicken eisschicht
genauso sei es auf der erde während der
letzten eiszeit aus könnten so etwas
auch in naher zukunft auf uns zukommen
fachleuten zufolge ist die aktivität auf
der sonnenoberfläche dramatisch gesunken
welche folgen hat das für das leben auf
der erde klicks zum science in future
hier gibt's drei mal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
activity glocke nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
klicks und gibt es jetzt übrigens auch
auf die ohren und zwar als podcast die
links zu spotify und apple podcast sind
unten in der video beschreibung also
ganze 50 eiszeiten gab es in den
vergangenen 26 millionen jahren auf der
erde wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass wir
die nächste miterleben und welche folgen
hätte eine eiszeit für das leben auf der
erde fachleute sind sich sicher dass
verschiedene faktoren für die entstehung
einer eiszeit entscheidend sind
beispielsweise die position der erde im
sonnensystem
aber auch lokale einflüsse wie der
kohlendioxid gehalt in der atmosphäre
doch diese abläufe und prozesse sind
super komplex und forschende weltweit
versuchen zu verstehen wie es genau
funktioniert denn nur dann lässt sich
abschätzen wie unsere zukunft aussieht
und ob auch uns möglicherweise noch in
der nahen zukunft eine eiszeit
bevorsteht denn klar ist jedenfalls auch
der menschengemachte klimawandel spielt
eine rolle aber jetzt erstmal zum
eiszeit alarm denn jetzt schlagen einige
medien alarm demnach ist die aktivität
der sonne stark verringert was für uns
auf der erde möglicherweise eine eiszeit
zur folge haben könnte nach angaben der
nasa steigt und fällt die aktivität der
sonne tatsächlich in einem elf
jahreszyklus laut der nasa forschern
befinden wir uns tatsächlich derzeit in
einem sogenannten grand soleil minimum
manche medien spekulieren dass der
nächste sonnenzyklus der bereits in
diesem jahr 2020 beginnt dramatisch für
uns werden könnte
denn eine geringe aktivität der sonne
hat folgen für das leben auf der erde
das zeigen auch beispiele aus der
vergangenheit das letzte mal dass die
sonne derart inaktiv war geschah
17 jahrhundert europa kam es zwischen
1645 und 1715 zum sogenannten maurer
minimum die sonnenflecken aktivität der
sonne war hier stark verringert auf die
gesamte nordhalbkugel bezogen wird die
kleine eiszeit auf den zeitraum zwischen
1250 und 1900 platziert plötzlich etwa
in den sommern zwischen 1275 und 1300
gab es eine abrupte abkühlung der sommer
und zudem auch deutlich mehr
niederschläge vorher war das klima eher
warm so dass sogar die menschen in
norwegen getreide anbauen konnten doch
der umschwung brachte extrem winter mit
sich und die sorgten dann dafür dass die
themse in london und die kanäle in den
niederlanden zugefroren waren viele
menschen starben
denn es herrschen hungersnöte und
seuchen bei der kleinen eiszeit handelt
es sich im gegensatz zu der klimatischen
entwicklung heutzutage um eine
natürliche variation des klimas und
wurde nicht durch die menschen
vorangetrieben
neben der verringerten soll an
intensität führten wohl auch andere
faktoren wie die vulkanische aktivität
auf der erde und veränderungen des
erdumlaufbahn fristen abholung trennen
die folgen der kleinen eiszeit sind
kurioserweise noch heute bemerkbar
das hatte ein us forschungsteam erst im
vergangenen jahr herausgefunden
sie wollten das rätsel lösen warum es im
tiefen pazifik immer kälter wird und das
ganz im gegensatz zu dem temperatur
trend auf der erde schuld daran ist
demnach die kleine eiszeit auf die das
wasser der pazifischen tiefsee mit einer
verzögerung von achtung mehreren
jahrhunderten reagiert zurückzuführen
ist dies wohl auf die sehr langsame
zirkulation der wassermassen innerhalb
des pazifischen ozeans dazu die
forscherin jbi die an der untersuchung
beteiligt war
diese gewässer sind so alt und seit so
langer zeit nicht mehr an der oberfläche
gewesen
sie erinnern sich quasi noch daran was
vor hunderten von jahren geschah als
europa einige der kältesten winter der
geschichte erlebte die fachwelt weiß von
der kleinen eiszeit nicht nur durch
gemälde auf denen die menschen in den
holländischen grachten
schlittschuhlaufen auch zahlreiche
temperatur rekonstruktionen die
beispielsweise durch die analyse von
baumringen möglich sind geben hinweise
auf diese dramatische klimaschwankungen
von damals die fachleute beziehen sich
bei dieser rekonstruktion aber auch auf
die sichtbaren flecken auf der
sonnenoberfläche wodurch sie
rückschlüsse auf die magnetische
aktivität der sonne ziehen können
während dieser 30-jährigen phase des
sogenannten maurer minimums konnten nur
50 sonnenflecken gezählt werden
insgesamt sogar 3579 komplett
fleckenlose tage in folge solch einen
aktivitäts tiefpunkt und das fehlen von
sonnenflecken zeigt die sonne eben auch
derzeit die ersten hinweise auf
eiszeiten die unsere erde in der
vergangenheit durchgemacht hat von
expertinnen experten bereits vor vielen
jahren erkenntnisse dazu sind natürlich
super spannend und wichtig um
einschätzen zu können wie es in zukunft
weitergehen könnte in der mitte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts hatte louis
agassis eine schweizerisch amerikanische
naturforscher spuren von gletschern
entdeckt die diese auf der erde
hinterlassen hatten sie hatten die
steine und felsen über weite strecken
geschoben in der fachsprache ist hierbei
von moränen die rede
vier weitere ice zeiten konnten dann
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
genannt werden diese fanden in der
sogenannten pleistozän epoche stadt die
vor 2,6 millionen jahren startete und
vor etwa 12.000 jahren erst endete doch
eiszeiten treten sehr viel häufiger auf
als man damals noch dachte vor allem der
serbische physiker emotion milankovic
sorgte dann für den entscheidenden
durchbruch auf ihn gehen die so
genannten milankovic zyklen zurück die
sich mit der erdbewegung beschäftigen
und sogar heute noch zur erklärung für
klima variationen
demnach sind es drei faktoren die die
erdumlaufbahn in bezug zur sonne
beeinflussen und somit auch darüber
bestimmen wie viel sonneneinstrahlung
die erde erreicht entscheidend hierbei
ist zum einen die exzentrische form der
erdumlaufbahn um die sonne
jupiter hat einen großen gravitations
effekt auf die umlaufbahn der erde und
sorgt dafür dass diese im zyklus von
96.000 jahren von kreisförmig bis
elliptisch variiert zum anderen ist es
die neigung der erdachse durch die die
jahreszeiten auf der erde entstehen
denn die hemisphären sind somit
unterschiedlich weit von der sonne
entfernt und haben einen anderen winkel
doch dieser winkel leben ändert sich und
zwar etwa
alle 41 tausend jahre und auch das hat
einen einfluss auf die temperaturen auf
unserem planeten zudem besitzt die
erdachse einen drehimpuls so dass sie
sich in etwa wie ein kreisel bewegt
produktion wie lankowitz geht somit
davon aus dass es im winter in jedem
fall zu eis und kalten temperaturen
kommt doch damit er seine echte eiszeit
gibt muss dieses eis auch den sommer
über leben und darauf hat eben nicht nur
die erdumlaufbahn einen einfluss sondern
auch andere faktoren beispielsweise die
werte von treibhausgas in der atmosphäre
und unser klima ein forschungsteam vom
potsdamer institut für
klimafolgenforschung hat und von vier
jahren 2016 berechnet dass der vom
menschen verursachte klimawandel
möglicherweise die nächste eiszeit
unterdrücken könnte
das muss man sich mal vorstellen demnach
sind wir menschen zu einer art
geologischer kraft geworden
der studie zufolge war wohl das
verhältnis von sonneneinstrahlung und
co2 konzentration in der atmosphäre das
schlüsselkriterium für die erklärung der
letzte nach gletscher zyklen in der
erdgeschichte die forschenden haben
hinweise darauf gefunden dass selbst
mäßige eingriffe des menschen in die
natürliche kohlenstoffbilanz des
planeten den nächsten beginn der eiszeit
um viele tausend jahre verschieben
könnte dazu der klimaforscher an dräger
noch polski auch ohne den vom menschen
verursachten klimawandel würden wir den
beginn einer neuen eiszeit frühestens in
50 tausend jahren erwarten was das
holozän als gegenwärtige geologische
epoche zu einer ungewöhnlich langen zeit
zwischen den eiszeiten macht unsere
studie zeigt jedoch auch dass relativ
moderate zusätzliche anthropogene co2
emissionen aus der verbrennung von öl
kohle und gas bereits ausreichen um die
nächste eiszeit um weitere 50.000 jahre
zu verschieben das fazit ist dass wir im
grunde genommen einen ganzen gletscher
zyklus überspringen was beispiellos ist
es ist eigentlich unvorstellbar dass die
menschheit in der lage ist einen
mechanismus zu stören der die welt wie
wir sie kennen geprägt hat die fachleute
aus potsdam schreiben in ihrer studie
zudem dass der beginn einer neuen
eiszeit normalerweise durch perioden mit
sehr geringer sonneneinstrahlung im
sommer gekennzeichnet ist und genau das
ist ja jetzt der fall
das zeigen auch die nasa bilder von
gewöhnlichen sonnenflecken die manchen
medienberichten auf eine kommende
eiszeit hindeuten können berechnungen
zufolge war die sonne seit beginn des
jahres 2020 bis ende märz etwa 76
prozent der tage ohne einen weiteren
sonnenfleck im vergangenen jahr 2009 10
waren es 77 doch das was gerade passiert
ist nichts außergewöhnliches es handelt
sich um die zyklen der sonne die etwa
elf jahre dauern und in denen die sonne
ihre energie mit einer bestimmten
frequenz freigibt wenn es nur wenige
oder keine flecken gibt handelt es sich
um ein sogenanntes solaris minimum in
diesen zeiten kann es tatsächlich zu
kälteeinbrüchen kommen und zu einer
klima abkühlung forschende aber geben
entwarnung so twitter zum beispiel die
nasa am 18 ich übersetze selbst ein
länger anhaltendes solaris minimum hätte
keinen großen einfluss auf den globalen
temperaturen eine neue eiszeit haben wir
also nicht zu befürchten und dafür gibt
es sogar zwei gründe zum einen sorgt die
globale menschengemachte erwärmung dafür
dass es keine nennenswerten
temperaturabfall auf der erde geben wird
nasa teams haben berechnet dass die
erderwärmung durch den menschen etwa
sechs mal höher ist als die abkühlung
die das sonnen minimum jahrzehntelang
auf der erde erzeugen könnte zitat
selbst wenn das rollo minimum ein
jahrhundert andauern würde würden die
globalen temperaturen weiter steigen
des weiteren zeigt auch eine aufnahme
der sonne vom 29 mai 2020 dass wir in
naher zukunft keine eiszeit auf der erde
befürchten müssen
denn sie zeigt den größten strahlen
ausbruch seit dem herbst 2017 die
aufnahmen des solar dynamics traktor iss
der nasa zeigen dass sich auf der
rückseite der sonne eine größere gruppe
von sonnenflecken gebildet hat und diese
sonnenflecken sind ganz eindeutig aktiv
am oberen linken rand der sonne haben
nämlich ausläufer sogenannte klasse m
flairs gebildet fachleute bezeichnen mit
diesem begriff einen strahlend ausbruch
der zweithöchsten kategorie
es handelt sich sogar um den größten
solar stahlen ausbruch seit dem jahr
2017 die neuen sonnenflecken weisen
darauf hin dass die sonne wieder erwacht
und in eine phase erhöhter aktivität
eintritt noch sind diese magnetisch
besonders aktiven stellen von der erde
aus nicht sichtbar
doch mit der rotation der sonne
werden sie in unsere richtung wandern
spannend übrigens dass jeder von uns
solche sonnenflecken beobachten und
fotografieren kann wichtig dabei einen
sonnenschutz für die augen
die flecken haben eine deutlich dunkler
farbe und heben sich vom rest der
oberfläche ab jeder dieser punkte hat
eine niedrige temperatur als der
restliche teil der sonne magnetfelder im
sonnenwind das sind nämlich höchst
seltsamen erscheinungen spannendes video
von über raum tv unbedingt anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
über tv ist ein absolutes muss für alle
wissenschaft interessierten also bis
dann bleibt dran